yeah 100 liberal for sure for sure and
then
i actually had a good friend in la i was
staying at her house
and we were watching cnn or something
before the last election
and she's like you know me and my whole
family vote for trump
and i thought she's a crazy person and i
literally thought i
probably can't be friends with this
person anymore that means she's evil
she's a bad human
like i was like are you guys like racist
knowing her boyfriend is a black man i
thought it was weird
and eventually i realized oh no her
family just owns a bunch of businesses
and employs a lot of people oh okay that
makes sense for them
why they would support him and then i
started to see the unraveling of all the
things i've been taught you go to enough
parties in hollywood you learn they're
all douche bags
it's just it is what it is 98
you know the ones who live in texas most
of the time they're pretty dope
um yeah but i i started seeing that
every single thing that these people
pretend they are
they are actually the polar opposite
you're kind of one of those people that
i feel like you're not really like a
pure political beast but when i open up
twitter or i open up
instagram i have a very short list of
people that i think are like kind of
sane these days
you know and and you're on that list did
you always care about politics did you
just get
kind of thrown into politics i've always
cared about it i
i was in politics when i was 18 years
old my very first
official official job was i
was voted into this like junior prime
minister of canada role
in canada i was working for the federal
government making way more money than my
friends were
working at like mpp and mp's offices so
kind of like our senators
and people wanted me to go into politics
i actually had a scholarship for
political science
if i went through the liberal party of
canada and i went
no i'm going to be a comedian it's about
the same the same and then
like seriously though so i really
started getting into it again a couple
years ago because
everyone started going nuts after trump
and specifically
i told this story a few times two nights
before
the last election i was on a platform
speaking at usc i was on a panel talking
about social media
um how it's in you know how it's working
through the election stuff like that
and people from hillary clinton's
campaign came up to me right before i
went on these
large men in suits and they told me
that i'm going to say on stage that i'm
voting for hillary
and i was like well i'm a canadian first
of all so i'm not voting for anyone
i don't get to they don't care about
that social media they don't care about
that yeah like
i'm here to talk about as the first
people monetize on facebook and like how
it all works
and you know that kind of stuff and
they're like uh we really strongly
suggest you say this
wow and i recognize the one dude because
he worked on bill clinton's campaign
years ago
and i was just like yeah no i'm not
gonna and once i'm on stage
doing the talk with everyone they put
the words in my mouth
so they said on the mic you know nicole
is just backstage saying that she can't
vote this election but she would for
hillary
and that was just like my freaking
switch in my head i was like
you [ __ ] okay
all right you're gonna put words in my
mouth and then i saw you know the media
over the last few years i saw all the
late night hosts i've grown up
loving and like looking up to just being
complete [ __ ] and spreading lies
i was like i'm gonna start swinging at
you guys
you won't see it coming and i'll take
you out in four episodes
so that's kind of where i'm at like i
just got pissed so i'm like okay i'll
start talking policy wow i
i totally did not know that about you so
when they when they did this when they
introduced usc like that
did you say anything when you got on
stage or were you just too nervous or
you just wanted to
oh no i did i did and i was like i
definitely didn't say that but hey like
i kept it sarcastic
but the same people wanted me to do an
interview with david hogg
who i am not a fan of i i kind of think
he's made a career off the
you know dead students in his class i've
inquired to see how much he charges for
appearances and i think a kid getting
thirty thousand dollars
to talk about his friends maybe his
friends being shot at school
uh is pretty grotesque how much of that
are you giving to the families
right thirty thousand how much that's
going to the families how much of your
activism is actually active activating
anything
and not a fan of the kid i think he's a
dick so
i was still going to do the interview
and i do it's what i think
sad that that happened to you it's
tragic but kid's a dick
so i was gonna do the interview and
his like one of the other fathers that
were part of the the shooting
um they think they're giant celebrities
now and they stood up
all of their interviews that day they
just oh sorry we're busy we're going to
a dinner
so there's these camera crews and these
people and we're like
we came here to do an interview it took
hours to get to this location in la
and they went to a dinner instead so do
you care about your message or you're
just trying to be famous
and yeah that started it and they still
reach out to me that group of people to
be like hey nicole can you help us for
this election i'm like
no i think you're dicks and i see you
lying constantly so
you've made an enemy and i'm gonna beat
you yeah but the beauty is i mean as
you're saying this and you're smiling is
you
really do do it through comedy like if
you want to tell people the truth and
not get punched in the face you got to
do it through comedy right that's uh
that's just kind of the way you got to
do it and that you really have mastered
that but i'm i'm curious did you
were you kind of right before then
because i want to get to when you kind
of came out for trump
but were you always we both had our kids
yeah yeah we had kind of similar events
yeah
yeah
yeah but but like what were you before
did you did you consider yourself
liberal conservative blah blah blah so
liberal
this is my liberal sweater by the way at
least liberal media okay
this is like freaking cnn reporters all
over it um
yeah 100 liberal for sure for sure and
then
i actually had a good friend in la i was
staying at her house
and we were watching cnn or something
before the last election
and she's like you know me and my whole
family vote for trump
and i thought she's a crazy person and i
literally thought i
probably can't be friends with this
person anymore that means she's evil
she's a bad human
like i was like are you guys like racist
knowing her boyfriend is a black man i
thought it was
weird and eventually i realized oh no
her family just owns a bunch of
businesses
and employs a lot of people oh okay that
makes sense for them why they would
support him
and then i started to see the unraveling
of all the things i've been taught you
go to enough parties in hollywood you
learn they're all douche bags
it's just it is what it is 98
you know the ones who live in texas most
of the time they're pretty dope um yeah
but i
i started seeing that every single thing
that these people pretend they are they
are
actually the polar opposite and i went
well
what's the opposite of [ __ ] i kind of
want to go that way
and i saw i caught you know even jimmy
kimmel i caught him multiple times
lying in stories yeah total lie and i
actually was responsible for editing him
twice he probably hates me
in the last year because i was like wait
a minute that doesn't seem right
i'd go to c-span and watch the full
uncut footage and then i'd
do a quick video on it and be like jimmy
kimmel did you just lie
to your entire audience let's see and he
did
and then he issued an apology a couple
days later on twitter um he was lying
about mike pence and one of them
but the more i saw this the more i was
like [ __ ] tricked me
you tricked me doesn't it doesn't it
seem crazy to you that you have to like
fact check comedians as a comedian
like if you would have said that to any
any like eight-year-old who wants to be
a comedian and your job will be to
fact-check comedians through comedy
you'd be like what the f are you talking
about
right you can swear with me it's okay i
saw you tell ben shapiro to swear i've
told him to swear multiple times too i
was
i was being hosti there but i would like
ben to say
yes i would yeah same just like just
once and then
put it on a loop and turn it to song
exactly yeah
well it's ridiculous because i don't
want to fact check their jokes i don't
give a [ __ ] about their jokes be funny
satire do it even though facebook is
censoring jokes now which is kind of
weird
um but i never thought i'd have to fact
check the premise
of their joke you know like nicole
arbour dyed her hair black no i didn't
what do you what are you talking about i
wouldn't do that or that's a sign i'm
depressed check on me
um yeah i don't i don't like it and it
got real weird
and then it got so weird that i started
researching myself like i was like okay
these crazy gun americans
and i flew down and i hung out with the
black rifle coffee guys
about two years ago this time and i was
like
okay yeah they're crazy but they're the
crazy that will rush in if there's an
issue
and save you we kind of need those
crazies you know
they're not going to use that gun on me
or some random they're going to defend
you if we need it
they're that crazy which is like a good
crazy yeah and then
i was scared of guns so i went to taran
tactical and i got trained on guns
and it was actually the military who
hooked me up with them and i was like
oh i see why people love doing this as a
hobby it's
dope like i've been like twitching while
i was in canada that i couldn't shoot
anything
targets uh and then i started
you know going through all the things
that okay trump supporters are racist
i saw that they're not trump supporters
are
anti-american they're this they're that
they're against gay people i'm like
well i kind of feel like i might be a
trump supporter based on what they
believe
and i've helped organize world pride
multiple times
i was on a on a freaking float beside
jonathan van ness
a year ago for the pride parade that
guy's pretty gay he's
he's very gay he's like on the gay
spectrum he's like the gay
that makes carson presley look like
walter cronkite how was that for a
reference i
don't know who those people are i'm just
kidding
he does seem like he's about to explode
into glitter at any moment which i love
but i saw him even lie he said in a live
stream recently he's like all trump
supporters are homophobic
and they hate gay people and they're
against the lb lgbtq community
i was like [ __ ] i helped build your
float yeah like
if i suddenly wanted to vote for trump
it doesn't change that i think you can
get married to whoever you want and be
happy and i love you
and i'm gonna dance with you in the
parade it just it was it got so
obvious and ridiculous and just purely
absurd that i was like
one side seems crazy and the other side
seems like
values yeah if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell